DANA PERINO, "THE FIVE"."
♪ ♪
NOW, I GOT TO SAY HE’S WORKING
HIS ASS OFF HERE.
>> I’VE GOT SAM WORKING MY ASS
OFF HERE.
SLEEPY JOE, THE GUY GOES TO HIS
BASEMENT.
>> ALL RIGHT.
AS THE ELECTION APPROACHES, WE
ARE WATCHING TWO COMPETING MAGIC
ACTS.
WHILE TRUMP IS IN THREE PLACES
AT ONCE, THE DEMS GIVE US AN
INVISIBLE JOE.
HE’S LAYING LOW, SAYING VERY
LITTLE AND THE LITTLE HE SAYS HE
GETS WRONG.
IT’S HISTORIC.
BIDEN IS THE FIRST CANDIDATE TO
SAY THE LEFT OF ME -- THE LESS
OF ME AT THE BETTER.
MAYBE HE’S BANKING ON THE FACT
IS NOT ABOUT HIM AT ALL, IT’S
ABOUT THE OTHER GUY, WHAT’S HIS
NAME, WAS IT GEORGE?
>> FOUR MORE YEARS OF GEORGE --
GOING TO FIND OURSELVES IN A
POSITION WHERE IF TRUMP GETS
ELECTED, WE ARE GOING TO BE IN A
DIFFERENT WORLD.
>> SO, IS IT FOUR MORE YEARS OF
GEORGE BUSH OR FORMER YEARS OF
JOE’S HOST GEORGE LOPEZ?
YOU DECIDE.
ONE GEORGE IS A REALLY, REALLY
FUNNY DUDE, THE OTHER IS LOPEZ,
BUT IF YOU WERE LOOKING FOR A
VANISHING ACT, JOE IS YOUR
GUIDE.
THERE’S NOTHING UP HIS SLEEVE OR
ANYWHERE ELSE AND UNLIKE TRUMP,
HE WON’T TELL YOU WHAT HE
THINKS.
HIS EVASIVENESS ON FRACKING
REVEALS HE’S WAITING FOR
INSTRUCTIONS.
AS FOR PACKING THE COURT, HE
BOLDLY STATES LET’S HAVE A
COMMISSION, WHICH IS LIKE BOLDLY
STATING I WANT A NAP.
BUT DRIVING TO PENNSYLVANIA THIS
WEEKEND I SAW NO SIGNS OF BIDEN,
BUT I DID SEE BIDEN SIGNS.
WHILE JOE HEIGHTS, HIS VOTERS
DON’T, BECAUSE VOTING FOR HIM,
IT’S SAFE.
NOT SO WITH TRUMP.
HE’S OUT THERE BUT WITH THE
EXCEPTION OF RALLIES, HIS VOTERS
AREN’T.
IT’S BECAUSE FOR THE FIRST TIME,
SADLY, SAYING WE’LL VOTE FOR
COULD GET YOU HURT.
BUT WHERE THERE WEREN’T ANY
SIGNS, THERE WERE INDEED
AMERICAN FLAGS.
MAYBE THOSE ARE SIGNS TOO.
A WEEK, NOT A SHOUT.
AS THE LAUGHTER VOWS PUNISHMENT
FOR THOSE THEY DEEM EVIL AND
CITIES ERUPT WITH RIOTS --
SORRY, PEACEFUL PROTESTS, IT
SENT A MESSAGE TO HALF OF
AMERICA, THE DEPLORABLES.
UNLIKE JOE, THEY WILL WAKE UP ON
ELECTION DAY BECAUSE THEY KNOW
IF THEY DON’T, THE MAGIC TRICK
WILL BE A DISAPPEARING AMERICA.
ALL RIGHT, JUAN, WE ARE BACK IN
THE BOXES.
I’M IN A VAN IN THE MIDDLE OF
NOWHERE, YOU’RE IN A VAN IN THE
MIDDLE OF D.C.
I’M SHOUTING.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THE
CONTRAST -- WHAT YOU MAKE OF THE
CONTRAST BETWEEN THE ENTHUSIASM
AND ACTION OF TRUMP AND THE KIND
OF LIKE ABSENT LETHARGY OF
JOE BIDEN?
I THINK I SET IT UP IN AN
UNBIASED FASHION.
>> IS THAT RIGHT?
FAIR, FAIR, ALWAYS FAIR.
LIKE THAT THING WITH GEORGE
LOPEZ, THAT WAS SO FAIR TO
JOE BIDEN.
>> [LAUGHS]
>> WHEN I LOOK AT THESE RALLIES,
GREG, I THINK TO MYSELF, YOU
KNOW, THIS ELECTION HAS BECOME A
REFERENDUM ON TRUMP.
HE DIDN’T WANT THAT.
HE WANTED TO BE ABLE TO MAKE IT
A CHOICE ELECTION, BUT IT’S NOT.
IT’S REALLY A REFERENDUM ON
TRUMP AT THIS POINT AND THE
RALLIES, YOU KNOW, I THINK TO
MYSELF THE RALLIES CAN BE FUN,
ENTERTAINING TO GO WATCH, BUT
THE RALLIES AREN’T CONVINCING
ANYONE THAT COVID IS GOING AWAY.
AT THE RALLIES AREN’T CONVINCING
ANYONE THAT SOMEHOW TRUMP HAS
COME UP WITH A GOOD HEALTH CARE
PLAN FOR AMERICA.
THAT’S JUST NOT -- THAT’S JUST
NOT TRUE OR REAL.
AND IN FACT, THE MORE HE TALKS,
SOMETIMES HE GETS HIMSELF IN BIG
TROUBLE.
THE OTHER DAY HE SAID AMERICAN
DOCTORS ARE IN FACT REPORTING
MORE CASES OF CORONAVIRUS
BECAUSE THEY GET PAID MORE IF
THEY DO.
OR ANOTHER TIME HE SAID
GRETCHEN WHITMER, THE GOVERNOR
OF MICHIGAN, AGAIN, HE ATTACKED
HER EVEN THOUGH SHE HAS BEEN THE
SUBJECT OF AN ATTEMPTED
KIDNAPPING PLOT.
HE ATTACKED THE GOVERNOR OF
PENNSYLVANIA, TOM WOLF, SAID IT
WAS THREATENING HIM.
I GUESS THREATENING NOT
PHYSICALLY THREATENING FEDERAL
FUNDS FOR THE CITIZENS OF
PENNSYLVANIA, SO I THINK TO
MYSELF IN ADDITION TO THESE
RALLIES AND POTENTIALLY
SUPER-SPREADER EVENTS, I THINK
HALF OF THEM HAVE BEEN LINKED TO
SPIKES IN CORONAVIRUS, I THINK
HE HURTS HIMSELF OFTEN IN THESE
RALLIES AND THAT’S NOT GOOD FOR
HIM.
>> OKAY.
SO JESSIE, I’M GOING TO QUOTE --
NOT QUOTE, BUT BRING UP SCOTT
ADAMS, WHO BRINGS UP THE CONCEPT
OF RECIPROCITY, THAT WHEN YOU
HAVE A CANDIDATE GIVING 110% UP
TO THE FINISH LINE, YOU FEEL
COMPELLED TO RECIPROCATE AND
VOTE.
DO YOU BUY THAT?
>> I DO.
PEOPLE ARE GIVING THEIR BLOOD,
SWEAT AND TEARS TO WAIT AND
DRIVE TO A RALLY WITH TEN,
20,000 OTHER TRUMP SUPPORTER’S
AROUND HIM.
IT’S FUNNY TO TRY AND LISTEN TO
JUAN TRY TO SPIN MASSIVE CROWDS
FOR A PRESIDENTIAL REELECTION
CAMPAIGN AS SOMEHOW A BAD THING.
NEVER IN HISTORY HAVE WE SEEN
PEOPLE TRY TO SAY THE MORE
PEOPLE TO SHOW UP TO LISTEN TO
YOU, THE WORSE YOU’RE GOING TO
DO ON ELECTION DAY.
IT DIDN’T WORK IN 2016 AND IT’S
NOT GOING TO WORK IN 2020 RIGHT
NOW.
DONALD TRUMP DOESN’T NEED TO
CHANGE A THING.
DONALD TRUMP IS IN THE DRIVER’S
SEAT.
IT’S JOE BIDEN WHO’S ACTUALLY
STRUGGLING RIGHT NOW AND YOU CAN
TELL WHY THE MEDIA IS TRYING TO
CHANGE THE WAY THEY FRAME IS
LIGHT SCHEDULE.
THEY USED TO SAY HIS LIGHT
SCHEDULE WAS SMART STRATEGY.
IT LOOK AT THE POLLS, AND
THEY’RE NOT SAYING THAT ANYMORE.
THEY’RE SAYING HIS LIGHT
STRATEGY IS A RISKY GAMBLE AND
IT IS A RISKY GAMBLE.
AND HERE’S WHY HE’S NOT GOING
OUT.
THERE’S A HOST OF REASONS.
ONE, HE CANNOT CONTRACT COVID-19
BECAUSE THAT DESTROYS THE
CENTRAL PREMISE OF HIS
CANDIDACY, WHICH IS "I’M SAFE,
I’M GOING TO LEAD BY EXAMPLE,
I’M GOING TO WASH MY HANDS,
SOCIAL DISTANCE, WEAR A MASK AND
PROTECT MYSELF," SO IF HE GETS
IT IT’S LIGHTS OUT.
HE’S GOING TO SHOW UP AND NO
ONE’S GOING TO SHOW UP AND
LISTEN TO HIM AND IT’S
HUMILIATING AND THE MORE HE
SHOWS UP, THE MORE STUPID THINGS
COME OUT OF HIS MOUTH, SO IT IS
SMART I GUESS FOR HIM TO LAY
LOW, BUT IT’S NOT GOING TO WORK.
RIGHT NOW TRUMP IS STORMING
THESE BATTLEGROUNDS.
HE IS NOW AHEAD IN THE REAL
CLEAR POLITICS AVERAGE IN
FLORIDA, IN OHIO.
AT LAST POLL CAME OUT IN
PENNSYLVANIA, TRUMP IS TOO.
LAST FALL THAT CAME OUT IN
NORTH CAROLINA, TYPE, LAST:
ARIZONA, TRUMP IS UP 1.
THE SAME THING IS HAPPENING THAT
HAPPENED IN 2016 AND THE MEDIA
DID IT TO THEMSELVES WITH THEIR
FAKE POLES AND THE FAKE NEWS.
IT’S SETTING IT UP FOR A HUGE
COMEBACK AND RIGHT NOW JOE IS ON
THE DEFENSIVE ON FRACKING, ON
OIL, ON CORRUPTION, ON TAXES,
AND THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN IS
DROPPING A MASSIVE ADDED BY
HITTING JOE FOR SIDING WITH THE
RIOTERS AGAINST THE POLICE.
>> YOU KNOW, DAGAN, WHAT I DON’T
UNDERSTAND IS I LOOK AT THE
PROVIDED MEDIA AND THEY
CONSTANTLY SAY HOW LIKABLE HE
IS, WHICH IS PROBABLY TRUE.
BUT WHY NOT HAVE MR. LIKABLE OUT
THERE MORE IF HE SO LIKABLE.
WHY ARE YOU HIDING THE MOST
POPULAR GUY IN THE WORLD?
>> WELL, I LIKE PEOPLE TOO IF I
DON’T HAVE TO SEE THEM OR HEAR
THEM OR ASSOCIATE WITH THEM AT
ALL.
SO I UNDERSTAND THAT.
ONE OF THE REASONS THAT -- ONE
OF THE REASONS THAT JOE BIDEN IS
LAYING LOW IS BECAUSE -- IT’S
NOT THE SUPER FLUB, IS A
GEORGE BUSH, MAYBE IT WAS
GEORGE WASHINGTON OR MAYBE IT
WAS GEORGE JETSON AND ELROY THAT
HE WAS TALKING ABOUT.
IT IS THE MOMENT WHEN A
POLITICIAN SCREWS UP BUT
ACTUALLY TELLS YOU WHAT HE’S
PLANNING TO DO IN THE WAY HE
VIEWS THIS COUNTRY AND
JOE BIDEN, JESSE MENTIONED THAT,
DID THAT IN THE DEBATE WHEN HE
SAID ESSENTIALLY I’M GOING TO
GET RID OF THE OIL INDUSTRY
BECAUSE IT’S DIRTY.
THIS GOES TO POTENTIALLY
DESTROYING MILLIONS OF JOBS IN
THIS COUNTRY.
DESTROYING THE PROSPERITY THAT
RURAL COMMUNITIES HAVE
EXPERIENCED BECAUSE OF FRACKING.
IT IS HANDING POWER TO NATIONS
THAT HATE US, THAT WANT TO WIPE
US OFF THE MAP AS WE FINALLY
REACH THE TOP POSITION IN OIL
PRODUCTION IN THE WORLD.
AND MORE THAN ANYTHING, IT’S
RAISING PRICES ON ALL AMERICA.
IT’S A TAX WHEN YOU RAISE
PEOPLE’S -- WE USE OIL AND
NATURAL GAS BECAUSE IT’S
PLENTIFUL AND CHEAP AND HE’S
PROMISING A REGRESSIVE TAX THAT
HURTS THE LOWEST INCOME
AMERICANS THE MOST AND THAT IS
HIS WORLD, WHERE AMERICA IS POOR
AND THERE’S MORE POWER IN THE
HANDS OF GOVERNMENT AND THAT IS
HELL ON EARTH.
>> LAST WORD TO YOU, DANA.
WHAT SAY YOU OTHER THAN HOW
HAPPY YOU ARE TO BE BACK IN A
VAN OR IN YOUR HOME?
>> YEAH.
JASPER IS NOT ALLOWED IN THE
VAN, SO THAT’S KIND OF A BUMMER,
BUT I UNDERSTAND WHY.
DAVE WOULD PROBABLY LET JASPER
IN THE VAN.
THE WORD OF THE WEEK IS
"ENERGY."
ENERGY WHEN IT COMES TO DEALING
OUT ON THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL AND
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS OUT THERE
DOING IT AND HE’S ALSO FOCUSING
ON THAT ISSUE IS DAGEN JUST LAID
OUT.
ONE OTHER THING I WOULD MENTION
NO IS THE DEMOCRATS AND THE
LEFT, IT’S SHOWING A LOT OF
ENERGY WHEN IT COMES TO
DONATIONS.
THERE’S SO MUCH MONEY HEADING
INTO THESE RACES.
REPUBLICANS ARE BEING OUTSPENT
IN MANY OF THE STATES AND YOU
DON’T SEE REPUBLICANS
COMPLAINING AND DEMANDING